bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
arthur de la marque spartan combien ce
matin ça ok spartan qui est une boîte
qui protège vos bijoux de famille et ça
on n'y pense pas assez mais c'est très
internet actu à ce que tu peux nous
expliquer ce qui se pa fans comment ça
marche
voilà tout ça avec plaisir donc spartan
on sauve l'humanité avec des caleçons
ça j'adore ça comme ça fait des années
aujourd'hui qu'on entend parler du fait
qu'il faut pas garder son téléphone papa
temps approche merlex omar daf avantage
sur les genoux est donc exactement comme
aurélien la part des gens toujours le
téléphone dans la zone dans les gammes à
nantes c'était c'était notre cas aussi
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a développé
le boxeur spartan qui est donc le
premier boxeur high tech
il protège les ondes de téléphones
portables et louis j
comme ça on a développé une technologie
brevetée savalou high tech d'accord et
qui permet de bloquer 99 notre constance
cinq essais en laboratoire
et donc ça permet juste d'avoir m sont
nombreuses heures le matin lorsque le
matin continuer à vivre sa vie d'homme
moderne met en jeu sa sentence et
pertinents
julie mardi s'est jamais demandé alors
technologiquement
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce parti comment
ça marche donc la technologie high tech
comment ça marche concrètement on a créé
un tissu unique composé d'un mélange de
fibres d'argent et peloton toute la
difficulté derrière c'était de réussir à
faire sauter dessus
en regardant une souplesse et un touché
soit le plus proche possible qu'elle est
donc aujourd'hui nos clients me disent
que
consciencieux confortable à votre
serveur
est ce que si tu touches touche la
georgie verte apercevoir que ça
ressemble vachement de la soie verre
d'eau
vraiment ils perdent alors du coup c'est
lors l'idée c'est un constat connu des
personnes qui sont fait un petit peu
trop
trop de haut niveau des partis ou alors
c'est comme vous avez une
sensibilisation à cette pandémie fiable
écoute ça c'est cette plusieurs années
on m'annonce et sur la femme qu'on
entendait déjà parler c
ces dangers des ondes et un jour lors
d'un dîner entre goku matin futurs
consommateurs
on a
tous sortis du porteur de la poche on
l'a mis sur la table on a commencé à
discuter du fait qu'on était
complètement
des années qu'on en parlait ce problème
des ondes
des années qu'on gardait le téléphone
qui sont l'apache est donc à partir
d'annoncés à dire qu'elle est si on va
pas changer nos habitudes à l'espagne
n'aurait pas changé de vêtements et
créer les boxeurs qui permettent de
garder les ondes à l'extérieur voilà
alors il ya un jardin
un brevet qui est protégé on this you
absolument notre technologie et profiter
elle est également certifiée par un
laboratoire indien
tant les notaires
loeb bien 99 cents à 105 101
y'a pas de problème c'est génial et un
spartan on peut trouver ou alors spartan
on est distribuée exclusivement sur
internet sur notre site internet spartan
underwear points comme et on livre
partout dans le monde
d'accord c'est cool plus gros marché
français
d'accord
on a une livraison qui se fait
actuellement
le reste combien ça coûte un cas sur ce
portable ça vaut entre 32 et 42 euros
32 42 ans comptait exactement nickel ok
bon ben écoute merci ce que tu vois les
choses à rajouter
eh bien rien de plus avec si vous voulez
nous aider à sauver la prochaine
génération avec des 420 rendez vous sur
smart and down comme est offert avec
génial bon ben écoute merci beaucoup je
vous invite à me laisser des
commentaires et à me dire si ça vous
intéresse
est ce que vous êtes vraiment
sensibiliser au fait de protéger vos
parties vous mettez tout ça merci
d'avoir gardé la vidéo merci beaucoup
les six mots comme d'habitude et jolie
pousse des commentaires abonnez-vous
parce qu'on va parler toujours et encore
plus des entreprises innovantes
françaises tour il s'agit de se protéger
merci et à bientôt
[Musique]